et j'accueille quelqu'un que j'adore
parce que ça fait à peu près douze fois
que je la reçois dans mes émissions ça
dort au début pas trop pire maintenant
ça va beaucoup mieux elle c'est un appel
vidéo un jour ni au bon soir renaud
muselier a santé le rpr qui monte
ah ouais j'ai pas dit que vers clermont
foot et j'ai mes repères qui monta à les
couples se forment laurent bon augure à
20h à rome comme michel verdier d'être
machel épouse michelle marc lavoine vous
connaissez linder voilà la connaît tout
cela a un ça va la somme au chiffre est
content alors liu
je vous accueille pour une comédie
musicale aux folies bergère qui
s'appelle sept filles et 7 garçons alors
l'histoire je leur racontais l'histoire
c'est les gens pensent que c'est une
énorme part tout ce qui se passe aux
folies bergère ne s'est pas le cas non
non non non c'est une histoire qui
connut d'ailleurs qu'elle ait donné lieu
à un film un film hollywoodien donc ses
sept frères qui vivent sans femmes 1
et puis à l'aîné qui va la ville pour en
chercher une il ramène emilie qui doit
éduquer ses frères un petit peu rustre
un petit peu lourdaud qui confondent un
peu les femmes avec des vaches laitières
faut le dire avec des bonniches et puis
franchement très dangereux partie et
puis à emilie ne veut pas être victime
de son destin donc elle essaye de les
deux les à leur apprendre à avoir un
regard un peu plus tendres sur l web
qu'est ce que c'est c'est ça de la
douceur n'obtient tôt avec il devait en
prendre de la graine
lorsque je compte 12 là c'est qu'on n'en
voit le magnéto n'ont jamais envoyé de
magnéto magnéto serge
posée
bien vêtu seulement comment seront des
jours que
nous militants
un homme ivre elle est
non jamais me demande vous déclare unis
par les liens sacrés du mariage
mieux alors habité de la comédie
musicale on chante parce que les
sentiments sont tellement fort qu'on
veut plus parler c'est une bonne
définition de comédie musicale je vous
oui je trouve pas ce qu'il faut mais ça
c'est peut-être on définit comme nous on
doit le faire parce que c'est vrai qu'on
commence par de la comédie on est dans
quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus
proche de nous et tout d'un coup il faut
se lancer ou en ré milieu d'une phrase à
chanter à pleine voix qu'alors il faut
bien trouver pourquoi
et bien parce que c'est beaucoup plus à
chaque fois et que si on est tellement
elles ont peu plus que chant que
chanteuse mais très bonne définition
d'un comédie musicale sur les sentiments
sont tellement fort qu'on l'ait j'aille
là on les chante ça c'est vrai j'aime
bien cette plantation du féminisme comme
ça ah oui ça c'est le genre de grands
bonds alors libre